this presentation is delivered by the
stanford center for professional
development
uh the entrepreneurial thought leader
lecture series oh my gosh now i'm being
projected all over
um i am tina selig and tom byers tom
raise your hand we are the
faculty hosts for this quarter's uh
draper fischer jefferson entre
thought leader lecture series and i have
a few announcements and things to tell
you
as you can see we've got a really full
room and for those who are still coming
in there's an overflow room upstairs
uh it's 191 is that right yes 91's and
there are probably some seats up there
and we've got it
live feeds so if you want a seat you can
go upstairs
we have a very special day today as you
see there are a lot of people
who you might not see on campus uh
before some from some new faces
we have a whole group here of 47
students from around
asia who are here could you all the
folks who are here with the aces summit
raise your hand
okay welcome i know you're having a
terrific week we also have an entire
delegation of students from latin
america can you believe this
who are over here okay maybe should we
like have a
like a soccer game or something outside
but uh
anyway so this is true and then if
you're a stanford student raise your
hand
okay so great so the bulk of the room is
stanford students
and uh as you know this is a lecture
series that goes on every quarter
all of you should have a sheet that
looks like this with all the lineup for
this quarter as you can see we have an
amazing lineup of speakers um and take a
look at this
i managed to sneak in at the bottom but
so don't tell anyone
hopefully people will show up for that
one too the only important thing to note
is when steve ballmer is here
we're actually going to move to memorial
auditorium there will even be tickets
and it'll be a whole different process
so
you'll learn about as we get closer but
uh we are delighted to have you here
and i am now as you know this is all a
videotaped and podcast i'm going to
start the formal introduction
uh for everyone who's out in the digital
world
okay great okay great
so um i would like to welcome you to the
first lecture of the draper fischer
jervidson entrepreneurial thought leader
lecture series
brought to you every week by the
stanford technology advantages program
and by basis
the business association of stanford
engineering and entrepreneurial students
it is brought to us online by scpd
and it is generously underwritten by
draper fischer jervison
uh i want to tell you we have an
incredible group of people here in this
audience
not just in this room but in our
overflow room and so for all of those
who want to follow
we also are now on twitter so you can
follow us online at
ecorner and in fact we
encourage you if you want to go and
listen to any of the archived podcasts
if you go to ecorner.stanford.edu you
can listen to all the podcasts of the
pro
past lectures for the past i don't know
five or six years
uh it is my extreme pleasure to
introduce our guest today
we have jensen wang who is the
co-founder of nvidia and i want to tell
you
18 years ago he was sitting in your seat
he was an ms student master student here
in electrical engineering
only two years after he graduated he
founded the company and he has been the
president
ceo and member of the board of directors
since its inception
one of the most wonderful things about
having him here today is our kickoff of
spring quarter
is he is also the incredibly generous
donor
to the school of engineering the new
building that you see going up just
outside
is going to be named the rank building
and he gave
30 million dollars to name that building
so hopefully 18 years from now
you guys will be doing the same so uh
without further ado
we have jensen ryan thank you
thank you tina i gave my last last
pennies to
jim plummer to build that building i am
now officially broke
so um instead of giving you a company
presentation today what i thought i
would
do is just have a conversation with you
you know at any time if you have a
question uh if you would like to change
the direction of our
of our conversation just raise your hand
and we'll we'll talk about whatever
comes up
a lot of people talk about and write
about
building companies and i can tell you
firsthand
that building a company is
extraordinarily gratifying it is also
incredibly hard and so the things that
that that you want to talk about
with respect to the company building
process
is rather expansive you could
talk about company building processes
from a lot of different perspectives
and so i'm going to try to touch on a
few of them that i think are
are particularly important in my
experience so 16 years ago
nvidia had three people three engineers
and
did i do something was it me
we had a perspective that that if
i was just
you think it's me
above i just did that
see it's you can't be you can't be
you can't control users stupidity you
know
you're good you're good it was probably
me i was sitting on it
all right so so um 16 years ago
we started nvidia and the the uh the
insight that we had
some people call it vision um
vision is an awfully big word to me
because i
i believe first of all vision matters
let me tell you that vision matters and
i'll help you understand that in a
second
but i like to use the word perspective
because it makes it possible
for anyone to have one when you say
vision it feels like
only a few selected visionaries of the
world can have one
but everyone has a perspective and
that's in fact all vision means
that you see the world in a way that is
either
different or uh otherwise
okay then than somebody else uh and you
see
opportunities that i think are that you
believe are particularly important to go
in and address
that you can address uh in a particular
way
and so perspective um our perspective at
the time this is 1993.
uh you guys won't won't remember this
but uh
the the pc um was windows 3.1
uh cd-rom uh was uh about to be
introduced
uh there were no pcs with networks
um wireless technology
uh the note if you said some if somebody
said radio
i think you would the word that would
come to mind is fm radio
uh and so wireless technology didn't
exist
the fastest microprocessor in the world
was a 66 megahertz 46 dx2
and i don't think any of you would even
use it in your tennis shoes today
and we would run our computers with that
and
the pc was was becoming used
for desktop or for office automation
our perspective was that this particular
device was going to be
unique in the sense that it has the
ability to run programs
and what if we gave it the benefit of
running 3d graphics programs
so that you could explore new worlds
play games you know play games
and so we started a company and and the
business plan
basically read something like this we're
gonna take
uh technology that was available only in
the most expensive
workstations we're gonna try to make it
reinvent the technology and make it
inexpensive
and the killer app was video games
and so i i took this idea to sand hill
road
and and they told me there was no video
game market
people don't start companies to play
games and um
my parents might i remember calling my
mom and telling her that i'm gonna start
this company and she says
you know what what do you guys do and i
said we built these things called 3d
graphics
chips and and um people would use them
to play games
and and then she she said why don't you
go get a job
and so and and so um uh now of course
of course games was was we believe uh
going to be a very large part of the
marketplace now we had that perspective
for very obvious reasons we grew up in
the video game generation
i was the video game generation i was
the beginning of the video game
generation
and so the the entertainment value of
video games computer games
was very obvious to me and i could
imagine how it could be a very large
market
and a very large industry for a lot of
the people that were
older that sensibility didn't exist
and so notice i just described to you a
perspective about the world
that we had that is apparently obviously
now true
because video games is the world's
largest digital media industry today
it is apparently true and yet at the
time
our common sense was unique
nobody would have created the technology
nobody would have created a company
with the sole purpose of building
technology
to make video games possible and so that
was our perspective
now we felt that that video games would
would of course
fuel the technology development but you
could use this technology for a whole
bunch of other
other reasons and one of my favorite
favorite applications this
happened about i guess about five years
ago
a small company struggling company here
in silicon valley
called keyhole and
they were they created a 3d virtual
world
and it had no application
this 3d virtual world and you start out
in space
you see the earth you zoom into any
location you wanted just by typing in
the address
i thought it was such a fabulous way of
exploring the world
going to places you've never been and
they couldn't raise a penny
and so we uh we uh um
i was so excited about the company we
put money into the company
and i went everywhere and showed that
demonstration i would tell people that
this is the way we're going to do search
someday
if you want to search for something uh
look for an address you would type it in
and we would fly you there
okay and and satellite images will
continue to download and before you know
it you're right there on the street and
you might even see some buildings
that that small company was eventually
purchased by google
and became google earth google earth is
now
the single largest downloaded most
frequently downloaded application in the
history of mankind
over 200 plus million downloads
um so 3d graphics could be used for a
lot
for a lot more than video games now that
that vision
if you will that perspective
um was unique at the time and hard to
sell
and so we had to go and explain it to
venture capitalists
who had to figure out whether the
technology was going to be possible how
big was the market because it was zero
billion dollars at the time
so how do you extrapolate how do you
scope the size of a market when its
apparent size was zero at the time and
you look at
analysts reports and you study market
research and
all of it would say approximately zero
it would never show up
it's a non-category a non-market
uh and so uh you know it's incumbent
upon
the the venture capitalist and of course
the founders
to try to figure out how to inspire each
other into doing something together and
so
sequoia capital and sutter hill were
venture capitalists
um and we got the company going with two
million dollars
now the the question about perspective
uh becomes uh very interesting uh in
other
in other opportunities in the company
other uh other circumstances in the
company and let me give you some
examples
um many years later sequoia capital
came to me and said you know there's a
couple of kids at stanford and
they have this thing and it's a
it's an internet thing and you just
type in you know what you're looking for
and it shows up
you know puts up the web website and um
i said yeah yellow pages i mean you know
no duh right we use it we and and
there's a variety of versions of it on
the web at the time
uh we use the internet just like
everybody else to to do ftp and also to
visit various websites uh and um and
they said should we invest in this
company and i said
there's no freaking way they're gonna
make money that stuff is free
right and so they said well you know we
can't figure it out ourselves
but it doesn't cost much to give them a
million or two uh
and uh and they invested in a small
company called what eventually became
jerry's company called yahoo
notice although i had the perspective
about one thing
i didn't have the perspective about
something else just because you're a
visionary doesn't mean your vision here
by everything
your perspective stems from your life
experiences what's commonsensical about
you what's interesting to you
and and so that's important to realize
that you have perspective too
therefore you have vision too now what's
interesting about these websites
to to follow on the yahoo story if you
remember there were
several other searches out there
alta vista at the time
excite at the time lycos at the time
right and now the question is they're
all doing search and now they did a
reasonably good job
now comes the question is what was their
perspective
how did they how was their perspective
different from one another
one website thought that they were a
destination do you guys remember that
we would be a destination kind of like a
channel
uh somebody said in fact since we're
going to be a destination
we would serve up content
and therefore the search part of it is a
commodity we'll outsource that
so all of the search engines which
started out as search
turned into destinations or portals
and they outsourced the search to
someone else which
made it possible for google to start
and so notice two companies doing
exactly the same thing
started with the exact same
fundamental core technology
ended up in radically different places
because they had different perspectives
they saw the world differently so
perspective matters
vision matters now in our industry
shortly after we were started 3d
graphics
for pcs and and consumer 3d graphics
became
the hottest hottest thing and so
everybody in silicon valley was starting
a 3d graphics company
we were in 1993 the only consumer 3d
graphics company in the world
silicon graphics up the street was the
professional
if you will a 3d graphics company by the
end of a couple of years or so 1995
there were probably 50 70 startups doing
exactly the same thing we were trying to
do
and over time we competed with
about 200 companies nvidia today is the
only surviving
computer graphics company in the world
and so the question is then
what happened competition is intense
everybody has smart people everybody has
money
we competed with ibm we competed with hp
we competed with silicon graphics
competing with sony 3dfx s3 series logic
big small international local we
competed with companies all over the
world so the question is what happened
i would argue that that
300 companies armed with exactly the
same technology
armed with exactly the same people
the company that wins and let's say they
all execute
and they did with 300 companies you know
50 percent of them were going to execute
at any given point in time
and so the question is why does one
survive
well i think that it matters to have
perspective and let me give you some
examples
i always believed that you need to
understand the reason why your business
work
what is the essence of your business
what makes it work
now the foundation of my business at its
core
is semiconductor technology here in
silicon valley we
we usually like to refer to
semiconductor technology as moore's law
moore's law is not so much a physical
law
as it's a law of competition
it is a law of challenging engineers
it's a law almost of setting pace and
moore's law approximately gives you
twice the performance
every year or two and so
understanding that the fundamental
ingredient of our
of our business improves by a factor of
two every year
and simultaneously reduces in cost by a
factor of two every year
the question is what makes a survivable
business and so our first
perspective was that 3d graphics was
insatiable it was insatiable
that if i made something twice as good
every year
even if the customer never asked for it
even if the customer told us it was too
expensive
even if the customer when you went to
float that product specification
to them told you that they're not
interested and in fact that was the case
i took
i took our product spec to uh to dell
and hp and ibm and gateway and they all
told me it was too much money
you're well outside of the boundaries of
what they were willing to pay for
when your customers all tell you not to
do something
the question is then what do you do in
our case
because we have this unique perspective
that 3d graphics was insatiable
and moore's law was our friend therefore
we should make our graphics processors
twice as good every year
and so for the first five years of our
company we just turned off our blinders
and said we're going to ignore customers
now which one of your of you guys are
going to go through your marketing
marketing courses and the lesson that it
teaches you is
ignore your customers well sometimes you
have to ignore your customers
and the reason for that is because they
don't know the nature of your business
and while the industry is being created
before there's common sense about the
rules of that business there is no way
they can
possibly know and so we
uh i took the last few million dollars
of the company's money
and uh built a chip that is way way way
too big
and our customers told us they we were
way out of bounds on cost
and they weren't going to buy any until
the day we showed up with the processor
we were in allocation through throughout
the entire life of that project
until our next generation product which
was twice its price
cannibalized the previous one and so we
grew and grew and grew for several years
then the question became what now
now you guys are going to learn that
innovation
is rather dangerous thing on the one
hand
once you discover a great idea
once you start discover a great idea you
rinse and repeat rinse and repeat and
you make that idea better and better and
better
well there's a laptop computer that you
guys have here or
a car or a microprocessor or in our case
a graphics processor
we made it better and better every year
at some point
it becomes good enough
moore's law is a wonderful thing
semiconductor technology
enables you to make amazing leaps and
bounds in technology
and at some point it becomes good enough
and so
in the this is probably in the late 90s
about seven years into our company maybe
six seven years into our company
i came to the conclusion
that 3d graphics was not going to be
sustainable
as a accelerator
or a fixed function device that renders
texture maps and
polygons on the screen that we had to
change the company
to make the 3d graphics processor
programmable
so that it could be an artistic medium
for expression
now this is a weird word here we are an
engineering company
and we now want to change this
chip to become an artistic
expression an artistic medium so that
all of the video games so that all of
the applications that were developed
on our chip would be stylistically
different
and we believed unless we could figure
out a way to make the content
richer and more interesting and
stylistically different
from one game developer to another game
developer to you know another
uh we would limit the life of our medium
and if our medium reached this end
we as the war the world leader uh would
also
uh would also see our end and so
we decided to make the gpu programmable
and
make it a medium for artistic expression
and invented a technology called
programmable shader almost every single
video game that you guys see today has
our fingerprint on it whether it's a
xbox 360 or ps3
or any pc game today you could see
elements of what
programmable shaders made possible
that started a whole new innovation
curve for us
and kept our industry vibrant but
the crossing from one generation of
technology to the next generation almost
killed the company
and so that process
of reinventing the company the
perspective that led us to a new idea
also risks the company in the process
and those are interesting conversations
that we can have
so there's perspective matters when a
company gets larger
you guys are you guys are going to learn
that that
as the the founder or as the ceo you
have to learn new things
and many of the new things that you'll
learn has to do with um
i'm building products at first and i've
just talked to you about building
products
soon you'll be talking about and
learning about building companies
and building companies means things that
are
soft and hard to explain like
building a company with a culture what
does that mean
how does the culture of one company
different from a culture of another
company
and why is it that this particular
culture is better for your company and
not for another
so the culture of a company is important
to find out to
to to put your arms around and to create
and develop
um how do you organize are you we were
just talking earlier with one of the
guys
are you functionally organized are you
organized in business units
how do you deal with multiple products
and multiple geographies and multiple
customers
and so that's the company building
process
it's mechanical it's interesting
lots of trial and error it's organic
people matter
personalities matter and if you guys are
interested in talking about that
i'm happy to talk about that as well and
then
i would say probably the the
the most important thing uh above that
is to realize that building up when
you're building a company and building a
product
skill matters intellect matters
training matters but it's not enough
the part of it that that
that is important to to realize about
building companies
is that it's a challenging and painful
and oftentimes
extraordinarily scary thing to do and so
unless you have
passion unless you really love the
process of building the company and what
you're trying to do
it's going to be incredibly incredibly
challenging and so
what i would i would um i would
leave you with is um when you're
building a company if you decide to
build a company
you have to ask yourself what is the
purpose that you're
building the company for is it that you
would like to build a company so that
you can sell it
make a fortune is it that you would like
to build a company so you can take it
public
you're just a serial entrepreneur you
want to build something let somebody
else run it build something
sell it whatever your reason is be
honest to yourself
it turns out that in my case
i just love the process of building
things
and i love being part of something
you know being part of nvidia and being
part of
a a people and being part of a cause
that is um that's inspiring to me
keeps me vibrant and and it's something
that i'm willing to do for a very long
period of time
and so i've been in it now for 16 years
and um i've learned a lot in the process
of being the ceo and the founder of the
company
and so maybe the thing to do is why
don't i open it up now and
let you guys ask me whatever type of
questions you guys have
yes sir what did your invent what did
your investors say about
your idea of reinventing your company to
include the
programmer cpu could you please
yes the question is what did our
investors
say about uh about us
taking the big risk of adding
programmable shaders
and reinventing uh reinventing that
product category and reinventing our
company
um first of all it's not a it's not a
conversation you really have with your
with your shareholders but you do have
the conversation with your uh your
management team first
uh your employee second your board of
directors third
typically is the way the process that i
i take
um and um
when you're in when you're in high tech
when you're in the technology industry
when the technology moves this fast
if you're not reinventing yourself
you're just slowly dying
you're just slowly dying unfortunately
at the rate of moore's law
which is the fastest of any rate that we
know
right the compounded rate of moore's law
is pretty
that unbelievable generating a lot of
money i know so it's scary
and so you have to um and this is
so the question is but we have a product
that's generating a lot of money
and it's very successful how do you
cannibalize it
there is there is a there is a theory
that if you don't cannibalize it someone
will and
surely will be cannibalized and so um
if you want to be a market leader you
have to take the initiative to
cannibalize your own products
and have your ideas cannibalize your own
ideas
um when we when we um went from
a fixed function graphics accelerator a
texture mapping engine
for games like quake 3 and doom in those
kind of games
um to a programmable shading
architecture
our first chip almost killed the company
it was called geforce effects i don't
know if any of you have ever
owned one of those geforce effects is a
is a chip
is a processor that you know
it's a baby only a mother can love i
mean it's
we we we took enormous chance in
building g-force effects
but it almost broke our back but if it
if we didn't build that ship
i am sure nvidia would be dead today i
am absolutely certain we'd be dead
it was one of the one of the biggest
gambles in our history
we had to create in instead of a
an api uh we had to go to a processor
with a
language we call it cg and a compiler
so it's kind of like like a processor we
introduced a new programming paradigm to
the world that it never understood
in the beginning and so it took a lot of
evangelism a lot of marketing
a lot of education but cg
inventing cg took us to unbelievable
places
and one of the one of our most important
work today
is related to using gpus for general
purpose computing
and it's um extraordinary that the
results of what we're seeing
and it wouldn't have been possible it
wasn't because of cg that we we started
okay so you have to take these leaps
questions yes sir um
some people are sort of see that gaming
is sort of moving more towards consoles
and away from disease
yeah is it harder to make profit with
you know when you have to negotiate with
sony or nintendo or whoever some big
company than it would be when you
sell individual cards yeah
the economics the economics of it of
building anything ultimately
comes down to the amount of competition
you have
you don't set the price the competition
sets the price the market doesn't set
the price the competition does
and so so um if your competitor
wishes to build playstation 3 um
as much as you do then then the
economics would be challenging
and so so um uh
there you just need to decide is it a is
it an economic
decision for you uh for example uh
there's uh the rumors that that we were
not enthusiastic in building some of the
game consoles and we were more
enthusiastic in building other game
consoles
um it came down to this for me i think
the um
you have to realize what is the finite
resource what is the scarce resource
that you have
as a manager the function of a manager
is to allocate resources
properly for the best return and so
if you think about our resources our
resource
is the finite number of extraordinary
engineers and how much time they have in
a day
to pursue whatever opportunities that
are out there
now if the number of opportunities that
is less than my supply of engineers so
therefore demand exceeds
is less than my supply then obviously
i'm very enthusiastic about it but if
it's the other way around
then the opportunity to build a game
console at terrible economics
or any project at terrible economics is
simply not worth it
and so i look at it irrespective of
competition
the competition sets the price but then
i get to decide whether i want to engage
in that project or not
you are in charge of your own company as
the ceo
right and so we decide whether whether
it's economic
and once you decide then you know it is
what it is so you have to be thoughtful
about what is your critical resource
do you have more of it or less of it
than the market demands do you have more
opportunity or less opportunity than
more than your
then your resource can support and then
what's the appropriate return on that
investment
uh thinking about not just your cost but
more importantly your opportunity cost
um and so so we look at it from that
perspective every single time
can you tell us a little bit about the
culture that you tried to set at nvidia
yeah that's a good question um the
question is what is the
can i talk about the culture that we're
trying to set at nvidia
um at the core of our company's success
is innovation now a lot of companies say
innovation is important to their company
invention is important to their company
however i don't believe you can
fundamentally say
that innovation that you want as a co to
nurture the spirit of innovation
to encourage innovation unless
you have a culture of risk-taking
we have to encourage our our engineers
excuse me our marketing people
all of our employees to take calculated
risks
in order to encourage them to take
calculated risks
first of all you have to teach them how
to do that that's a skill
a matter of skill then the second part
of it is a matter of courage
most people hate to fail
are you guys do you guys agree with that
unless you guys want to be successful
let me say the positive way if you want
to be successful
i would encourage you to grow a
tolerance for failure
to develop a tolerance for failure now
when i mean a tolerance for failure i
don't mean
g what jensen just told me is sleep in
until noon
okay don't do any of my homework flunk
out of all my classes because that
defines failure
right that's not what i said what i said
is
what i'm trying to say is that i want
you to try
things even though it is impossible to
calculate
precisely that it would lead to success
that your instincts your intuition
is something you ought to follow if it
wasn't because of
following my own instincts or the
founders instincts or
many of our employees instincts why
would we be where we are today and why
would we have invented
things that the markets never had before
the world's never had before
so you have to have this this culture
or tolerance for risk-taking but the
thing about failure is this
if you fail often enough
you actually might become a failure and
that's different than being successful
and so the question is how do you teach
someone how to fail
but fail quickly
and to change courses as soon as you
know it's a dead end
and the way to do that is we call it
intellectual honesty
um we assess on a per
on a continuous basis whether something
makes sense or not
and if it's the wrong decision let's
change our mind
and you know a lot of people say ceos
are always right
and they never change their mind that
doesn't make any sense at all to me
especially when it violates the first
principles of what we want the company
to become
an innovative company that invents
amazing things
that solves problems for the world that
it sometimes
didn't even know it had
if you want to do that then you have to
cultivate
that um tolerance for risk taking and
you have to
then teach people how to fail but fail
quickly and inexpensively
and how to be direct with each other
that
that this is the wrong approach and
what's the better approach and then you
know be flexible enough to change
courses and quick
and so that that type of culture if you
will
um in today's you know if you guys were
to start a company and you were built
building a website with an internet
service of some kind internet-based
service of some kind
with the competition coming from all
over the world
and it's 24 7 and ideas
take no time to experiment and it
you know a particular website or
particular company company could be
throwing ideas out into the world
20 a day and so unless
you are thoughtful about
risk-taking and being able to change
your mind reacting to the market
conditions
um and being flexible how are you going
to stay alive and so you could you could
almost see
what i just described in the nature of
older companies and the nature of the
newer companies
the modern companies if you guys you got
i'm sure you guys all go to google's
website
almost every single applications in beta
form
they're trying all kinds of stuff right
they're trying all kinds of stuff
if they call it production and it
doesn't work well you guys would just be
upset at them
so they call it beta if you notice
they call it beta so that they could try
a lot of things and if it fails
take it out if it's bad take it out if
it works do more
and so innovation requires a little bit
of experimentation
experimentation requires exploration
exploration will result in failure
unless you have a tolerance for failure
you would never experiment and if you
don't ever experiment you would never
innovate if you don't innovate you don't
succeed
you'll just be a dweeb
that's it any other questions
yes sir did you choose your co-founders
and additional team
um don't ever don't ever go into
business
with anyone you don't deeply trust
and they were two of my two of my
closest um
closest colleagues and i trust them
completely
and they're they're wonderful friends
even today
so by the way as a ceo selecting people
is
99 of the job um what applications do
you see
driving demand in the general purpose
which is like what's going to be like
the next big thing
so the question is what is what do i see
driving the demand for this thing that
that we're um we're pushing right now
called
gpu computing using the gpu for much
more than just graphics
for graphics there's a there's a model
of graphics
that we call computational graphics so
so it's um using programs to generate
the images
the algorithms are no longer cast in the
silicon the algorithms are actually
software
and it could be ambient collision it
could be ray tracing could be all kinds
of interesting algorithms
that that people are are going to
explore for the future
we observed and it was a it was in fact
um this is give you another example of
innovation uh
and and and with stanford is fabulous
we when we invented geforce effects
although it wasn't a very successful
gpu for graphics researchers around the
world noticed that it had a programming
language called
cg c for graphics and then you could
program this gpu
to do other things aside from graphics
and it had 32-bit floating point ieee
compatible 32-bit floating point
and so some smart and some smart
researchers
many of them were here at stanford just
bought a graphics card from fry's
and started writing programs and they
discovered that
if they really worked hard and do all
these men you know these
algorithmic gymnastics they could get
something
an algorithm you know it could be nano
molecular dynamics
could be computed computational fluid
dynamics to run
20 times faster and they couldn't
believe it
how do you speed up an application 20
times
well the interesting observation that we
made is that we speed up 3d graphics up
applications which is basically
something you can do in software
a thousand times over a cpu all the time
so what if we took all of those parallel
processors that were inside our gpus
and make it completely programmable and
expose it through a programming language
called c
right c and now in the near future c
plus
um imagine
imagine the type of problems we could
help solve and so
whether it's weather prediction or
seismic analysis
or uh you know taking your your ct scans
and reconstructing the human image for
the body
the the the body from it um all kinds of
very computationally intensive
applications
we could accelerate fifty times a
hundred times now just to put it in
perspective a hundred times
is in moore's law time approximately ten
years
now to put ten years worth of computing
resources in the hands of scientists
researchers engineers unbelievable
benefits
and so the risk was really large however
to make our gpu even more general
purpose
because every time you make something
general purpose
you know what right a swiss army knife
it's dangerous because
whenever you make something general
purpose or swiss army
knife like you move away from your core
business
it's much much better to have a very
specific niche
to have intense focus on a particular
market segment
and you guys will learn all of this in
marketing
when you make something general purpose
you're all things to all people
you become you know what is it uh
matt what is it jack of all trades
master of none
very very dangerous move now we we
thought that it was just too important
for us not to do it so we decided to
make that move
and um uh it's it's fabulous results
okay so those are some of the some of
the things that we're seeing now
yes ma'am
so especially in the initial stage how
can you find each of your
positions in a company and how can you
distribute
the topic okay so her question is
we were friends in the beginning we're
friends now
how do we figure out uh who's the right
position
and how do we distribute the profits
okay
and so i i won't say anything funny just
as
i'm not misunderstood but but
all of our pay were identical
and we all had identical share in the
company
um so that's that's uh
that's just simply fairness now the
question becomes
governance there's the part of it which
is equity
equity as another way of saying what's
fair
right so we all had the same salary all
all three of us were making a hundred
thousand dollars a year
okay and we all had a percentage of the
company equal percentage
now you can't run a company though you
can't build a great company
when you have three people who has to
vote on everything
and with equal share of responsibilities
you simply can't
that becomes a leadership question that
becomes a governance question
that becomes a management question right
that becomes
a question about building a great
company
i don't recall exactly uh
exactly um the conversation but i think
it kind of went like this
all right jensen you're the ceo right
okay
that was done
that was that was basically the process
um i think that some people are are
you know i'm not particularly i'm not
from a personality perspective i'm not
particularly outgoing
and so uh that's not a neces necessity
for being
a good ceo um but um
as a personality i've always been able
to see
around the corners if you will i can see
around the fuzzy edges
and i think ceos and
leaders need to be comfortable with
ambiguity
ambiguity meaning that you know what
does the future look like
well it's hard to say some people hate
that
some people just say jensen tell me what
you need to have done
and for how with how much resource and
by when
okay some people rather me tell them
that
hey look there's this um there's this
opportunity out there not sure what it
is not sure how big it is
but it kind of feels like this let's go
figure it out and let's build a business
some people are very comfortable with
that and so this
this ambiguity um is is important to uh
to uh to to be comfortable with i guess
and i think that all ceos that are are
very successful are comfortable with
ambiguity
and i'm very i am very comfortable with
yes yeah what percentage of your initial
investment was yours
like uh how do you get the rest and
also like how many times was your
proposal for and
for help with the investment
so i was 30 years old and i never taken
a single business class and and i've
never taken any marketing classes
and and i've never used never used the
at the time it wasn't powerpoint was
called persuasion
on the on the mac it was called
persuasion and so
um i bought a mac so i could i could use
persuasion
and and
and then i try to create a company
presentation to take it
to venture capitalists um
the process kind of went like this we
started my first official day of work
was
my 30th birthday february 17th and
we got the company funded and so once we
got started
the question is what are we going to do
you know how does it all work out how do
we start the company
and so um we met every day the three of
us
in in one of the founders townhouse uh
in fremont
and um and we would get together and and
there would be
nothing to do i mean what do you do you
got three guys get together you just
talk
you know so so what did you guys do last
night uh what you know what did you have
for dinner
i mean so you talk about that for about
six months
okay and and the big event of the day
would be um hey where do you guys want
to go to for lunch
and so you know philly cheesesteak today
or you know
chinese food tomorrow or whatever that
would be like a big deal and then after
a while
it was like could you put some donuts in
the fridge in the morning for when we
come
i mean so that would be a big deal for a
while and so that lasted for a few
months just the three of us like that
i know it sounds pathetic but it's it's
true because
at that time i'm reading about books on
how to start companies and
i'm trying to figure out you know how to
go raise money and
you know what's a venture capitalist and
how do you incorporate the company into
those kind of things now pretty soon i
met a
meta meta lawyer went to it went to a
law firm called cooley godward
and they helped us incorporate the
company
and the amount of money that he said he
says um you know we need we need some
money
from you so that we could price the
shares
and also to incorporate the company so
he says how much money do you have in
your pocket
i said two hundred dollars so he says
okay give me 200 i gave him 200
and for 200 i bought
15 percent i think it was 20 of nvidia
so it was a good deal yeah
20 yeah and then went i went back to the
house and then
went back to the condo and and uh they
all they both gave me 200
and they both got 20
and that's how it worked literally
it's not that much more you know don't
here here's here's the thing
nvidia i never finished my business plan
i know it i know um
we we never finished um a business plan
uh never could figure out how to finish
a business plan to tell you the truth
um and uh and if if i would have
finished that book and i went to
went to borders and got gordon bell's
book
how to start a high tech company it's
like this thick
if i would have read the whole thing i
would have been dead now
we would have run out of money ran out
of time and so i i read i read the first
three four chapters and i you know i i
got to go to work
yeah so so i um incorporated the company
they introduced us to
two venture capitalists um and i just
went to their office and
told them what i like to do uh the the
thing that that gets the company
funded and when you're when you get to
that point you just have to remember a
few things
uh vcs don't invest in
in business plans because business plans
are easy to write
i couldn't write it but other people
could right
and so so um they invest in this they
invest
in great people
and so so the question is is
do they trust you uh your reputation
matters
your history matters um because
uh because i had done so much work with
um andy bechtolsheim which was
another graduate of stanford of stanford
and the founder of sun
uh and worked with uh the founders of
synopsis and lsi logic
and the and you know we we were all
very successful and we did good work um
your reputation will precede you even if
your
business plan writing skills are you
know
inadequate the second thing is you need
to have a vision that's sufficiently
large to invest in
because they their statistics their
probability of success is rather low
and if they need to put in 10 million
dollars if the market's only 20 million
dollars large
they'll never get that 10 million
dollars back with with reasonable return
but if it's a 200 billion dollar market
then of course it's a rather different
thing
okay so the size of the market and they
want to know that that um
at least there is a clever idea
that the market has never never done
before so they that last part
is probably second you know last i said
i said it last because also i think it's
least important
you have to you might have to reinvent
yourself over time
and if you want to reinvent yourself you
need to have great people that's why
great people so important
yes sir who were some of the people that
you considered to be
your mentors when you were getting
started and what was some of the best
advice that you got from them
um so the question is what what um who
are some of the mentors
and uh what were the best advice i got
um i i truly believe that if you want to
be successful
you you um a successful habit
is to have the capacity and the
willingness to learn from just about
anybody
and i do you know i learn from just
about anybody
and it could be a little thing could be
a big thing
you know if it wasn't because of my kids
i would be
i would i would i would miss the whole
internet age
you know i would have missed youtube and
facebook and
twitter and you know i mean without so
you need to
you need to know that that um the world
changes and and you want to be able to
learn from just about anybody
and so i i'm surrounded with
extraordinarily talented executives and
professionals of all walks of life and
so
you just have to make sure that you're
you're willing to learn from just about
anybody
some of the some of the great advice
that i've
i've had over the years focus
laser beam focus you know don't do too
much do
do a few things well and do it with
extraordinary intensity
and i you know focus focus
matters if you look at what i do with my
time
i wake up in the morning and the first
thing of my time is nvidia and the last
thing i do is nvidia and i do that 24 7.
and if i can figure out a way to do that
for another 50 years we're going to be a
good company
yes
your ambiguity as ceo what's your best
and worst estimation of the future of
you and your company
okay so um her question is
um she started out by saying that that i
was a successful i'm a successful
entrepreneur and
and what are my biggest challenges now
and
considering that i like ambiguity what's
my best estimate of the future for the
company or and and for myself
um uh the biggest challenge
with building a company is the
reinvention of the company
every successful thing needs to be torn
down
at some point and be rebuilt
it is unfortunate but true and the
reason for that is because the
technology either gets good enough
um and therefore you have to reinvent
and sometimes the invention process is
disruptive
sometimes it's in fact destructive and
it could be it could destroy
you could destroy what you have built in
the past and so the reinvention process
is very challenging it's gut wrenching
takes a lot of courage
and it really tests your conviction
in in the technology industry
reinventing the company
every 10 years is almost a necessary
thing
so that's when i say challenging i don't
mean
bad challenging i think that's fun
challenging
i love the process of reinvention okay
so that's fun challenging
what's my best forecast for our company
i think that nvidia
has the opportunity to become one of the
most important technology company
companies in the world
and um i hope that i hope that it does
and my best forecast for me is that
i am 80 years old and i'm here talking
to students
and i hope i'm still the ceo
yes yes sir questions about the first
few years
of real startup is very critical you
have to be survived you make sure your
cash is
positive yeah the constant cash flow
from your nvidia case how do you manage
that
so the gentleman's question is has to do
with in the beginning
uh survival is important cash is king
just so that there's no no no ambiguity
about this
survival is always important cash is
always king
and so as the ceo you're either making
money saving money or raising money
and and if you're not making money
raising money
and saving money you ought to be doing
those three things
that's a simple it's just stay focused
on those three things
and so when you're during the beginning
in the early days i was raising money
all the time
as soon as i was done raising this round
of money i got to raise more money
you know you're always raising money
just maybe maybe there was a week break
in between but i was raising money all
the time
i was as a startup you're always going
out of business
right that's the definition of a startup
an enterprise that is nearly out of
business all the time
that's the definition of a startup
question
yes ma'am are you prepared
well because i wanted i want this uh the
question is how do i deal with
leadership
succession uh as a ceo and for our
company
well i want this job until i'm 80 i just
said
i'm just kidding one of the primary
roles of a ceo in order to grow the
company
in order to grow the company in order to
make make nvidia one of the most
important technology companies in the
world
and make make significant contribution
to society
in order to do that you have to
cultivate new leaders
so that they can have new ideas and grow
new businesses and
and you know maybe run a different
geography run a new different product
line and so
i spend most of my time these days most
of my time these days
sitting with our general managers and
sitting with our leaders and helping
them think through
strategies and helping them think
through challenges and helping them
think through
um product roadmaps and how do you think
through transitions and
you know team building organization
creation
you know how to manage how to how to
create processes that that
last the test of time so so you know
these things are
are lessons that that i'm supposed to
pass on and i do
and i spend a lot of my time doing that
i believe
i believe this that succession planning
by a priori picking out
three people that the board should
consider in the case that i get run over
by a bus
is a toxic toxic process
i know that has been it has been um uh
thought of as a
methodology uh um succession planning
but i think it's just very toxic for the
environment because everybody's trying
to figure out who got selected and who
didn't
um i think that it's a much much better
process
to focus on ultimately developing the
next generation of leaders
so that in the case that something
happens i'm not the right ceo anymore
there are many choices for the board to
choose from
including outside okay so those are i
think the company building process
focusing on that is the positive way of
thinking about succession planning
a good question how about i take one
question and that's it
okay yes yes
a good question but it's okay
in america any question from from our
latino crowd here
and i have is friends who are engineers
they have many
many brilliant ideas but they don't feel
motivated because
they have money and they were looking
for
people who could make
these ideas real and they
are only working for other people and
they don't
realize this idea i don't know what you
say
well first of all so so her i think let
me see if i can paraphrase the question
uh you you know you know friends who
have a lot of ideas but they also have a
lot of money
and so they don't really feel that
motivated to do something with those
ideas
um i you know you know first of all
i money i hope that if i if i leave you
with anything
money is the only singular reason not to
start the company
because starting companies are it's a
very very unlikely
probability for success and so if you're
looking for
if that is your reason for doing it you
will likely regret
the experience you should start the
company and build a company because you
just
you so believe in your idea you so
you're so passionate about it
and you want to build something great
the only reason you want to do it it
just comes along
um it's fine i i have i have um
i have plenty of money and uh yeah
and and and but but it doesn't motivate
me
nor does it demotivate me because it it
wasn't
and so i would urge you to ask yourself
and for your friends to ask ask
themselves what is the purpose that they
want to start a company
ideas ideas are a dime a dozen
there's so many ideas if you want ideas
you're going to get a lot of ideas in
this room
and so ideas don't really matter um you
have to have a perspective that's unique
that you feel really strongly about it
that you're willing to
persevere almost any challenge
that's the reason why you should start
okay
thank you everybody
on behalf of them
you